i got this for my daughters
and it's the irish fairy worry plaque so
you put your hand on there and if you
can see
it turns you can see it's red and then
you keep it there and you kind of
let go of your worries and then oh
and it's just a great way listen we
could all use a little imagination
and if you have to grab a worry plaque
put your hand on it think something
beautiful
take a deep breath and let those fairies
take your worries away well
that's one way it's green it worked
[Laughter]
soothing and comfy take a good whiff
ross
oh i'm up in it already gosh
it's from the lavender comfort neck wrap
and
eye pillow um by lavender life
company and bffs guess what rossi
what we are so happy to report that
we're going to be shipping
all these out to you at home you can get
cozy
company asap and the neck wrap is full
of four
pounds of non-gmo grains and lavender
and you can zap it in the microwave
for some heat therapy i know remember in
like the 80s when it was like you could
microwave things and put them on your
body
i don't know well i do was that a thing
it was a thing and so i have to say this
is a
way more chic version and the eye pillow
is a pound and it delivers that soothing
lavender scent
straight to your face and it's all grown
on a family farm in west
michigan it's all the snuggly goodness
you can get
at barefoot dreams
now listen this is a family-owned
business based out of malibu california
that makes the comfiest and coziest
blankets
and sleepwear and robes and apparel for
kids
and i have one of these blankets one
and my kids and i fight over it and i
have to tell you
you will never feel anything like that
this is like a hybrid coziest blanket
slash
like fluffiest towel you've ever felt
you know
i don't know how they do it but the good
news is
they do and it is the perfect mother's
day gift
[Music]
you